if the moon is constantly getting
farther away from the earth every year
about two inches a year okay so about
two inches a year then why do we have a
super moon where the meet where the moon
appears larger okay first I got to nip
this in the bud okay don't get me
started
I'm getting you start don't get me
started get you start here all right so
we there's something called a super moon
okay I don't know who first called it a
super moon all right I don't know but if
you have a 16-inch pizza would you call
that a super pizza compared with a
15-inch pizza how many meat toppings are
talking cause if I'm talking like
totally loaded yes I'm going yes it is
the cheese in the crowd right
it brought cheese in the crust like the
super moon is a 16 inch pizza compared
with a 15 inch pizza it's a slightly
bigger moon I using the heck gypsy super
moon not I excuse me that's like super
huskin I'm not going there Super Tuscan
wine right yes yes they're super because
they're super price because I got four
or five times regular you've been paying
like a hundred bucks to vertebrate
alright so we wasn't able so most off of
the universe you're right they bring up
Tuscan wine I get a little bit a I'm
always about wine so there is no super
moons which some say so the super moon
is the moon's orbit around the earth
it's not a perfect circle sometimes
closer sometimes it's farther away
gotcha and every month there's a moment
when it's closest occasionally That
moment when it's closest coincides with
a full moon people are calling that a
super moon I but they're super half
moons alright it's not every month so
one of those phases is the closest I'll
give you an old super Crescent super
happy super no no okay I told you don't
get me started
not only that I wish I was going to
tweet this while we're saying here now
first already ahead do you know the full
moon has no higher tidal effect on earth
than any other phase of the Moon now you
just make it stuff fun alright haven't
you come back more Startalk